hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the garage now
this isn't the week rugs is just normal
grudge mark alright
Marv mark hey in case you guys didn't
know my name is Mark okay Lanisha
oh okay proceed all right so I've I
haven't actually seen the garage movie
I got a general idea general letter of
acceptance care center volunteer form
okay all right
I haven't seen the movie but I have a
general idea I saw a scary movie for
that's kind of kind of had to do right
hello
okay so care center means I'm obviously
taking care of somebody
mark F thanks for filling in on short
notice the laundry is in the upstairs
bedroom mom's pills are in the bathroom
she needs one every four hours dinners
in the fridge makes your mom eat
something whose mom your mom my mom
whose mom do we know each other's mom I
know your mom oh right
what did I do
I thought I clicks on a cabinet who
doesn't know your mom is what I was
gonna say hi Ruby crackling sounds like
someone's burping in the back hang on
what's going on this doesn't look like
any layout of a house I've ever seen
hi
it is Japan so it's all weird pills I
okay stop with the grilling is that a
big part of the movie like the old movie
someone's just going seriously can I
move through this house normally what do
I have a problem with walking yeah I'll
open that
cab pictures my name oh no what is this
the Internet why are there so many
pictures of cats in here I hear you
Oh someone's at the door
better go answer it I don't even know
what's going on
what am I supposed to do in here this
doesn't really make much sense where's
the mother who's mom
why does she live here oh hi I'm just
because the stage of what the hell is
going on I don't even really know it was
this do what why what some things look
like they're faded off the list of my
stuff I was supposed to do where am I
going up to the attic why why why am I
even still in the house
okay good I'm running out
hi oh is that my hand the curse has
claimed another victim what I don't even
know what happened
how did I jonbi that's a lot of John D's
John Doe what I did how did I what did I
know oh I didn't get dinner from the
fridge before I went in the attic or
something what the hell happened did I
do something wrong
huh I don't want the active desktop
give me back did he give it back Mary I
don't know I mean it was creepy and a
lot of you been suggesting that for a
while I humming I really know much about
the grudge so I really have a lot to say
as far as a game goes I'm sure it was
interesting but there was no objective
there was no point there was no purpose
other than throwing you in on the
assumption that your caretaker there was
no room to build up atmosphere there was
just that and just what it was I mean
there was no no real reason or purpose
buying the scares that I kill but I
don't know I don't know about the grudge
I mean it startled me but that was about
it so I don't know yeah well let me know
what you guys think of that because I'm
not exactly sure maybe I should go watch
the movies but
I don't really know so thank you all so
much for watching hope you enjoyed it
for what it was and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
you get wait do let wait decide to share
hey Mark you I see something funny fine
motor back whatever body